virtual reality Peter bran I mean it
right now we're all in no you're not
this is the real world this is not
virtual reality I know you spent most of
last week with the stupid dumb oculus
goggles on your face I want to talk to
you about that first of all did you have
lines around your face this weekend yes
no I didn't last this weekend but no
lines you get lines in your face for
solid 20 minutes okay great it's like
taking goggles off after doing a bit of
like scuba diving it's almost exactly
like taking there you go except no
fishies although I'm sure they have the
fishies for your demo as well yes coming
soon so you spent all last week or what
seems like the majority of last week
playing lots of different games on the
oculus rift I actually focused on a
small handful of games okay I wasn't
trying to go for the entire gamut of the
launch lineup because we're trying to
review some game so in order to do that
I have to focus a little bit yeah so
you're playing games like chrono see
Valkyrie go see Valkyrie Lucky's tale I
tried playing some adrift before I got a
sick sorry uh yeah I realized like
really okay toned outfit wasn't a joke
was it that's my thing to say hey uh so
I guess I want to talk to you you're
like the litmus test right you're the
person who's actually spent a bunch of
time minik because most of the people
i've talked to you about this have spent
you know 20 minutes on on a show floor
somewhere or i've spent an hour maybe at
a developer's so what were their like
time frames you were using the oculus
for and how did it feel coming out of
that yeah well coming out of it
definitely depends on what experience
you're playing I use it anywhere from
five minutes in a sitting to a couple
hours at a time and you certainly feel
odd after a long session coming out of
it because you moved from one your sense
of presence has now shifted back to
reality and with that looking at my
watch was really strange because really
get the passage of time just it it's
skewed slightly that's a bit weird yeah
it's not so it's not like I thought only
20 minutes had passed and it have been
two hours [ __ ] existenz right but I
mean it's on the order of
be what felt like an hour was to like
something like Jackie can it can it can
be pretty dramatic is that the case was
regular video games maybe as well as yes
yeah it feels more yeah but raised equal
when you when you pair that that feeling
with what you get from VR which is you
know immersion even if it's a game that
is not like a first-person experience of
trying to recreate reality right like no
matter what anything you're planning in
VR that's all you're looking at that's
right as you can see no matter where you
turn your head yeah so you are immersed
in that experience even if it's not the
world that you're immersed in
specifically so like I play a lot of
rocket League just randomly for like you
know 20 minutes here or there or maybe
like an arrow here there and what I find
is a lot of the time I'm thinking about
just regular day-to-day stuff like I'm
thinking about my taxes or thinking
about what I got to do in a week I'm not
really like actively involved in what's
happening on the screen in Virtual
Reality you feel like you're sort of
more engaged with the moment to moment
what the hell is going on or does your
mind still wander it's an escape really
yeah yeah I mean it I can't make it any
simpler than that yeah like really you
at least I felt very detached when I was
playing a game that I was invested in
mentally um you know all those things I
was just describing a minute ago kind of
inform this this isolation that you have
from yourself even to a degree because
there's nothing to distract you it
really isn't and so like what's it like
taking it off and then coming coming
back is only like physical aspect to it
that's like trying to recenter yourself
or is it more of a like when you come
off a road across Syria you're like oh
okay now feed back on terra firma and
I'm kind of I'm used to this uh if
things felt a little alien for the first
minute or two because you really are
acklam like as much as it takes you to
acclimate to VR coming out of it
requires acclamation as well and you
know tell like I can understand how what
I'm saying sounds like maybe extreme or
somewhat contrived but it but at least
myself I was very much into the
experiences that I was engaging with and
coming out of them felt very strange
very strange not in a bad way and not in
a way that lasted for a long time or
gave me an existential crisis or
anything like that but it was definitely
like
okay this is actually my day this is
what I'm doing I'm not following this
Fox around the woods I'm not crawling
through a dungeon you know fighting
monsters yeah that kind of thing not
that I ever really believed I was but I
think you get what I'm saying so it cuz
to me that sends that what you're
talking about their sounds far more I
don't know like impactful then maybe any
one of the individual video game
experiences like just the sort of the
sense that exists around using virtual
reality and the way in which it sort of
messes with your psyche a little bit
yeah that almost sounds like what's more
interesting than the games themselves is
that is that why you're so excited about
at this moment yes the sort of the
grander feelings that VR gives me is
what has me interested in what it can do
for gaming but also what it can do for
passive experiences like video it's it's
it's really important that people give
this a try and really think about how it
makes them feel before writing it off
because VR is freaking special it's very
different from everything we've done
before and you know I put up my review
for Lucky's tale today which is the game
that's bundled with every head said it's
really middling it's not that great a
third-person color for a platform yeah
and you know what like it's it's fine
it's totally fine but it doesn't really
sell what's important about VR and so I
stated as much and some commenter was
saying like oh you really shouldn't be
doing this because I'm people are going
to think that VR isn't that great like
you should really try to like prop it up
so everyone likes VR and it's like no
because the the tech is there if you
read the oculus rift review you can see
why I think that's important but the
games right now still need to catch up
eval Cree oculus or Kronos those are
both really great games but they're
still just kind of tiptoeing into the
waters of what VR can do yeah
you